great news mario fans lots of mario
games are coming to switch and best of
all
super mario 64 sunshine and galaxy are
coming this month
i'm chasity and this is your save save
for thursday september 3rd
super mario brothers is turning 35 this
month and to celebrate nintendo is
bringing
a bunch of mario games to switch the big
news is super mario 3d all-stars which
brings a bunch of old favorites to
switch
in the latest nintendo direct nintendo
finally announced its plans for super
mario bros 35th anniversary celebration
and the big conclusion was super mario
3d all-stars
all stars include super mario 64
sunshine and galaxy
these aren't remakes but they do have
new features and enhancements
they all have improved resolution 64 has
rumble-enabled controls on the joy-con
and sunshine has a new 16x9 aspect ratio
you can also listen to their soundtracks
yes galaxy 2 is missing so some fans are
disappointed
the collection costs the same as a full
price game and it's out on september
18th
nintendo also mentioned that the
collection will only be available
through march 2021
so you've got plenty of time but it
won't be on sale forever
but that's not all because there are
even more mario games on switch
first the original super mario all-stars
collection is available today for
nintendo switch online
that includes super mario brothers mario
brothers 2 mario brothers 3 and super
mario the lost levels
super mario 3d world and bowser's fury
comes to switch on february 12
2021 it adds online co-op and includes
bowser's fury a new expansion with new
levels
and then there's super mario bros 35
which is basically a mario brothers
battle royale
35 players run through a level and every
enemy you beat gets sent to someone
else's screen
compete to be the last mario standing
that's coming on october 1st
only for nintendo switch online members
like 3d all-stars it's only available to
the end of march 2021
but it won't even be playable after that
according to nintendo
and lastly we have mario kart live home
circuit which is a new mario kart game
with a twist
it's a mixed reality game where you can
make your own tracks using physical
checkpoint flags
then you drive a real mini card around
with a camera on its back that transfers
the footage to your switch
it also supports online multiplayer
mario kart live home circuit is out on
switch on october 16th for 100
that's your save state and that's a
whole lot of mario games i'm gonna have
to start saving up because i want
almost all of it especially 3d all-stars
which game are you most excited about
and what is your favorite mario game of
all time
let me know in the comments below or
reach out to me on twitter i'm at
chastity underscore v and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you